welcome to the show everybody i said
yesterday which was our first show of
the year and the first show of the week
that as soon as we had kind of catch-up
data
uh from the holiday weekend about covid
we would look at the numbers and that
it's expected that the numbers are off
the wall shocking appalling numbers and
indeed they are when it comes to cases
the numbers are appallingly bad when it
comes to testing in terms of the
difficulty of getting a test and the
extremely high positivity rate of tests
showing how incredibly widespread this
omicron variant is
but we continue to see
death numbers
that while they are still tragic
are making us hopeful
that this omicron variant is going to
burn through the population
in maybe the next four to six weeks
without
a proportionately
uh high death toll
and then go now what happens after that
there are three or four different
perspectives which we will eventually
talk about but let's take a look at the
numbers and they are just incredible how
contagious this thing is is really
really hard to believe
in the united states now a a just a
a vertical increase and we'll look at
the exact numbers if you look at the day
by day
days of nearly six consecutive days of
nearly six hundred thousand cases in a
single day and a lot of the backlog data
is still being catalogued but these are
incredible numbers
at this point if we have five hundred
thousand cases a day that we know about
we would expect that the real number of
infections is between 1 million and 1.5
million actual infections a day to
account for home tests that don't show
up in these data and to account for
people who never get tested 20
positivity rates in many states and big
cities
um if we look over at uh this is this is
death let's not go there yet if we look
at global cases we see that global cases
are now reaching 2 million cases a day
that we know about
that we know about
and with the difficulty of tax testing
that also exists in many other countries
some to countries of great testing some
countries don't we can also safely
estimate the real number of infections
if officially it's two million cases a
day there's probably between four and
six million infections per day or even
more
um if you think about just the u.s
numbers actually but before we get to
that article from cnbc
u.s reports over 1 million new daily
coveted cases the u.s has reported a
record single day number of coveted
cases with more than a million new
infections a total of 1.02
million new cases were reported monday
yesterday per johns hopkins university
as the highly infectious omicron variant
continues to spread throughout the
country and beyond the u.s also has the
highest seven day average of new daily
cases in any country tracked by johns
hopkins
um
this brings the total confirmed cases to
56 million
over 827 000 deaths now the record
single day total may be due in part to
delayed reporting from the holiday
weekend so that's what's really
important to look at when you might be
saying
david wait so if if a million were
reported yesterday
why does a worldometer say that it was
only 426 000. a million were reported
yesterday
some were from january 3rd some were
from january 2nd somewhere from january
1st and december 31st so
we're rapidly getting up there for a
moment
let's imagine
that the real number of cases just to
make the math easy is 1.6 million a day
why do i pick 1.6 million well the u.s
has a population of about 330 million so
1.6 million 1.65 million would be
exactly half of one percent per day if
you start doing the math and you think
about well some people
if you have three
shots of moderna or pfizer
you're about 75
protected from symptomatic infection so
when we think about the population if
there's some people who have recovered
from prior covid
and have protection some protection from
omicron it's diminished but some
protection from cron you have some
people then who even if exposed aren't
going to get it you then have people who
have three shots which gives you
some significant protection against
omicron although vaccinated people are
getting this all over the place we know
that so you've got that population and
then if every two days one percent of
the population is getting it you start
doing the math
30 days of this high case rate is going
to have most of the country exposed
many will get it
many will be asymptomatic some will be
exposed and fighted off thanks to
vaccination or prior immunity in 30 days
there can only be one path for omicron
and it's down very quickly and we're
seeing that in south africa now could
there be another variant of course could
there be all sorts of different things
of course but when you have something
this contagious where every two days one
percent of your population is getting it
in a country this big and you have some
immunity in the population and you have
some vaccine protection in the
population
at some point something has to break and
so the the cautious optimism is that
this will get us
much closer to the end of the pandemic
phase what about deaths the good news
continues to be
that deaths are not spiking
the omicron spike in cases started right
around thanksgiving and while there has
been an increase in deaths the average
daily going from about 900 up to about
12 1300
um
cases are dramatically higher
and the deaths are not yet spiking and
it's been a while we're into five weeks
now
in south africa omicron led to a case
increase of
150 x a day
150 times increase
in cases
and deaths only doubled now south africa
is different in a lot of ways much
younger population than the us as i said
yesterday
etc etc but the fact that deaths are not
spiking in proportion with cases is very
good globally
deaths continue to decline
at the start of the um the omicron
spread
global deaths were at about 7000 a day
and now global deaths are under 6 000 a
day
we're cautious we're cautious but this
is
reason to be cautiously optimistic
one last thing on this uh the cdc has
shortened the waiting period for pfizer
coveted boosters to five months remember
the cdc had said
get your third dose at least six months
after your second dose
now the cdc is saying five months and uh
it is believed that part of the reason
is that that third dose is so
much more effective at preventing
symptomatic illness from omicron that
the recommendation is changing so that
is a very good thing these are the
numbers as we have them right now we're
going to continue to follow them it's
both appalling
the difficulty of getting tests
uh and the number of cases
it also is assigned to say wow if cases
are this high
and we're not seeing death spike
dramatically that's a really really good
sign we will follow the science
one of our sponsors is magic spoon
breakfast cereal sweet and tasty like
the cereals i loved as a kid but without
the sugar or the carbs every serving of
magic spoon has zero grams of sugar only
four net carbs 140 calories and packed
with 13 grams of protein perfect if
you're doing keto perfect if you're
doing low carb great if you're just
trying to reduce your excess sugar
intake and because it's packed with
protein it's great before or after a
workout magic spoon flavors include
cocoa fruity frosted peanut butter
blueberry and cinnamon they're bringing
back cookies and cream they're bringing
back maple waffle you can build your own
variety box and try them all magic spoon
is so confident in the product if you
don't love it as much as i do they will
refund your money no questions asked go
to magicspoon.com pacman the link is
underneath this video and you'll get
five dollars off when you use the promo
code pacman at checkout